>> I TOLD HIM HOW PROUD OF HIM I
WAS.
THANKED HIM FOR ALL THE WORK HE
AND HIS ARE DOING TO SAVE LIVES.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE BRAVE MEN
AND WOMEN FEDERAL FOLKS WORKING
SO HARD.
ALL WORKING ONE TEAM.
HEARING HEAR THAT THAT FROM THE
GOVERNOR AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL
FOLKS.
>> Todd: PRESIDENT BIDEN
PERSONALLY CALLING FIRST
RESPONDERS INCLUDING MEMBERS OF
THE COAST GUARD TO RISK HEIR
LIVES FROM OTHERS FROM THE
DEVASTATION OF HURRICANE IAN.
>> Carley: ZAC LASH SAYS HE WILL
LOSE HIS JOB BY THE END OF THE
YEAR THANKS TO THE PRESIDENT'S
OWN VACCINE MANDATE.
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL
WALTZ IS A FORMER GREEN BERET
COMMANDER AND MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE
AND HE JOINS US NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, IF YOU CAN BELIEVE
IT, THE MAN THAT THE PRESIDENT
CALLED TO THANK FOR HIS HEROIC
ACTION IS GOING TO BE FIRED AT
THE END OF THE YEAR BECAUSE OF
THE PRESIDENT'S OWN POLICIES.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>>
>> YEAH.
HE IS ONE OF 2600 COASTIES.
THAT ARE IN THIS POSITION AND I
CAN TELL YOU WHAT, THE DISABLED
WOMAN IN A WHEELCHAIR THAT HE
STRAPPED TO HIMSELF AND
EXTRACTED -- SAVED HER LIFE.
SHE DIDN'T CARE THAT HE HADN'T
RECEIVED A VACCINE.
WE HAVE OVER 1,000 NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN AND WOMEN IN THE
FLORIDA NATIONAL GUARD ARE THAT
ARE WILL THE IN THE SAME
POSITION ON THE VERGE OF GETTING
KICKED OUT OF THE GUARD, WITH NO
PAY AND BENEFITS.
LOSING THEIR RETIREMENT.
THEY ARE OUT THERE ON THE FRONT
LINES RIGHT NOW.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
GIVING WATER, FOOD, PROTECTING
FROM LOOTING AND CRYING, THEY
DON'T CARE.
THE FLORIDIANS THIS THEY ARE OUT
THERE SAVING DON'T CARE.
PENTAGON IS STICKING TO THE
STUBBORN ASININE POLICY THAT IS
NOT FOLLOWING THE DATA AND THE
SCIENCE.
LOOK, THE CDC HAS CHANGED THE
GUIDELINES.
IT IS CLEAR THE VACCINE DOESN'T
STOP THE SPREAD.
YOU KNOW, ONE COULD ARGUE IT
MADE SENSE WHEN WE THOUGHT THAT
IT DID, BUT IT NO LONGER DOES
THIS.
IS AN EXTREMELY HEALTHY
POPULATION.
THE FACT THAT IT IS GOING TO
EFFECT READINESS DOESN'T HOLD
WATER.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, ON TOP OF
IT ALL, GUYS.
WE HAVE A MAJOR RECRUITING
CRISIS.
WE ARE FALLING SHORT,
PARTICULARLY IN THE ARMY BY
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF MEN
AND WOMEN THAT THEY CAN'T BRING
IN TO REPLACE THESE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ON THE VERGE OF KICKING OUT.
THEY HAVE GOT TO STOP THIS
MANDATE IT.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AND IT'S
HURTING PEOPLE THE POINT THAT
YOU MADE IS THE EXACT SAME ONE
THAT MR. LOESCH MADE.
QUOTE, IF I HAD ASKED ANY EVER
THE PEOPLE I SAVED YESTERDAY IF
THEY WANTED TO COME WITH ME EVEN
THOUGH I AM UNVACCINATED.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM WOULD
HAVE SAID YES.
HE THANKED ME.
YET THE VACCINE MANDATE IS WHAT
IS KICKING ME OUT.
I JUST LOVE MY JOB AND I'M
REALLY GOOD AT IT.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A JOB THAT I
WAS BORN TO DO.
DO YOU THINK ANY OF THIS PUBLIC
PRESSURE WILL FORCE ANY OF THESE
WASHINGTON BUREAUCRATS TO SAY,
YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO CHANGE THIS
UP NOW OR AT THIS POINT IS THIS
ALL ABOUT SAVING FACE?
>> THERE IS JUST THIS STUBBORN
IDEOLOGY THAT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE.
LOOK, I GET IT, YOU KNOW, I'M A
COLONEL IN THE MILITARY AND AS A
GREEN BERET AND NATIONAL
GUARDSMAN, YOU GIVE A PLATOON AN
ORDER TO TAKE THE HILL.
THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT ORDER
FOR GOOD MILITARY AND
DISCIPLINE.
AS A LEADER AND THIS IS WHAT I
AM ASKING OF THE PENTAGON
LEADERSHIP.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO REEVALUATE YOUR
ORDERS.
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR ORDERS
WHEN THE SITUATION CHANGES.
AND, YOU KNOW, IF YOU EVER
SOMEONE GETTING INTO A SUBMARINE
OR GETTING INTO A TANK, THAT YOU
THOUGHT WERE GOING TO INFECT
OTHERS, THAT'S ONE THING.
BUT SINCE THE VACCINE NOW
DOESN'T STOP THE SPREAD, IT'S A
PERSONAL HEALTH DECISION, THE
CDC AGREES, LET'S REEVALUATE
THIS ORDER.
IF WE FLIP THE HOUSE I HOPE TO
BE THE CHAIRMAN OF THE MILITARY
READINESS COMMITTEE.
IF THE PENTAGON WON'T CHANGE WE
WILL LEGISLATE IT AND FORCE THEM
TO CHANGE.
WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THESE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN OUT ON THE
FRONT LINES ALL DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
MANY OF WHOM, BY THE WAY, HAVE
NATURAL IMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY
ALREADY GOT THE VIRUS AND THE
PENTAGON IS NOT TAKING THAT A
COUNT EITHER.
IT JUST MAKES NO SENSE TO HURT
THESE FOLKS.
WE ARE TALKING BIG NUMBERS,
GUYS.
YOU KNOW, 15,000 JUST IN THE
ARMY ALONE.
ON TOP OF THE 15,000 THAT THEY
FELL SHORT.
THAT'S FROM A RECRUITING
STANDPOINT THAT'S THREE
DIVISIONS WORTH OF SOLDIERS AND
OH BY THE WAY WE HAVE THE
RUSSIANS THREATENING NUCLEAR WAR
AND A MASSIVE MAJOR CHINESE
BUILD-UP.
COMMON SENSE HAS GOT TO REIGN
HERE.
>> Carley: LATEST U GOV CBS NEWS
POLL.
68% OF PEOPLE BELIEVE RIGHTS AND
FREEDOMS ARE AT STAKE IN THE
ELECTIONS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE VIEW THAT SEE
THE OVERTUCKER THE ROE V. WADE.
THAT COULD ALSO MEAN HOW PEOPLE
VIEW PANDEMIC POLICIES AND
LOCKDOWNS AND EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED IN 2020.
15 SECONDS TO YOU,
UNFORTUNATELY, BUT YOU STILL
THINK THOSE THINGS ARE ON TOP OF
MIND FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> WELL, I THINK, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, THE ECONOMY, CRIME,
BORDER, INFLATION ARE TOP OF
MIND FOR THIS MIDTERM.
BUT THIS FREEDOM ISSUE, YOU ARE
RIGHT, IT QUESTIONS BOTH WAYS
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WHETHER IT COMES TO THE
MILITARY, THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
HIMSELF, JOE BIDEN SAID THE
PANDEMIC IS OVER.
SO LET